welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this section we're going to talk
about the relativistic doppler effect
and we make good use of our space-time
diagrams which we discussed earlier
so the situation is as follows to
simplify this we have a a source which
is emitting pulses so the waves are
pulses every now and then there is a
beep and another creep and another peep
and those those two pulses they travel
with their velocity with their wave
velocity
um and they have a word line represented
here in the space time diagram this is
pulse number one
and this is pulse number two
the distance between those two pulses is
our period the period of our wave which
we call tau
the question now is how is this being
observed by our observer which is moving
with a relative velocity v with respect
to the source
so let's analyze this
so if you want to characterize or find
our position x1 and x2 we can do this by
saying
x1 is equal to c tau 1 at t1
or equal to x0 which is the distance
of the observer to the source plus v
times t1
v is the velocity in which
the source is moving
and similarly for tx2 we find c times t
2 minus tau
and that's also equal x 0
plus v times
t 1 and t 2.
so the distance in time
still in the reference frame s of the
source is given by c times tau over c
minus v
and the distance in space is given by v
times c times tau over c minus v
so the question is not how this is
observed how this is seen by the source
but how this is being seen by the
observer so we have to do apply loans
transformation
so in the s prime frame which is the
observer frame
we find delta t prime is equal to gamma
delta t minus v over c square delta x
and then we just fill in the information
as we discussed before
um
tau prime is then
gamma times c tau
over c minus v
times one minus v square over c square
and then we make use of beta equal v
over c
and we
make use of
of gamma equal 1 over square root 1
minus beta square and we find then
this is a little bit of an algebra
exercise here let's say the period
now is given by
1 plus beta over 1 minus better square
root of that times tau
and the frequency is the inverse we have
one minus better over one plus better
square root of that
times the frequency
so we just calculated relativistically
how the period and the frequency of a
wave
is
is loans transformed
you